let's have a moment of silence for owen
wilson
okay we can't keep it too long because
of youtube algorithms so here's the
thing about this man
episode number four was amazing
episode number four was awesome which
i'm so glad we got episode number four
coming off of episode number three
because episode number three was boring
man
it was like the empire strikes back
version of loki riot it was just
boring as hell so here's the thing about
this man like
i think the story of sylvie so far
is interesting but honestly man does her
whole story really just boil down to a
petty revenge story because if it is
that's the least interesting thing ever
right like from what i gather just from
what we've seen right here's what we can
kind of piece together
that she was a little girl and for
whatever reason the reason it was was
not given to her
by rinslayer when she asked her in the
elevator what was my next event when
slayer's like i don't really remember we
don't know what the nexus event was
but we know that it was significant
enough the tva snatched her up and they
basically brought her into the tva
itself which scared her so she
pickpocketed rin slayer took her tin pad
tried to go back to her universe only to
find it was wiped out and then she's
been on the run for the tva ever since
and i guess that's
it right it's just you know you hurt me
so i'm gonna hurt you back is that
really all it is because that's a pretty
flimsy
and kind of lame origin story but
regardless
silly herself is cool so i guess it
makes up for it but man
there were some mind-blowing moments in
this show okay so here's the thing as
soon as owen wilson came out of that
little portal thing with loki and you
saw rent slayer and those those tva guys
standing there i was like all right owen
wilson ain't making it oh and wilson's
not gonna make it son
and then like the sad music started
playing you know how it is you know the
sad music starts playing and then it's
like oh my god no they're gonna kill
owen wilson
and then sure enough man is bow they
pruned him and i felt so bad because i
was like no
owen i always wanted to see you on the
jet ski man like
hopefully at the end we can see him on a
jet ski right just kind of living his
best life or whatever it is but it's so
cool man because people are finally
being woken up to what's actually going
on i like that it's all kind of falling
apart
b15 and owen wilson and all these people
are starting to realize okay so like we
really have been kidnapped by the by the
tva which leads me to believe
i don't think they're all variants
variants are people who deviate from the
existing timeline and then in turn are
brought into the tva but
what was it that owen wilson was doing
that he deviated from the timeline right
i mean
seemingly the only way to deviate from
the existing timeline is to have the
ability to alter time right so if it's
all a pre-guaranteed outcome then what
could owen wilson have possibly done did
he stumble across a time machine right
did he stumble across doctor doom's time
platform
it's his real name owen reese i have no
idea what what the deal is with his
character right but regardless of the
situation
i don't think they're all variants i
think a lot of them are just innocent
people who have just been snatched up by
the tva and just fallen in there and
then just told you've always worked here
and that's basically it but regardless
of the situation
it was amazing man like you know when he
came out and he died it was like wow you
know it tugged at the heartstrings
in the most powerful moment the same
thing with loki man i never saw it
coming with loki getting pruned
not in a million years i never ever ever
saw that coming and i will say this you
know the more i look at ren slayer the
more i think she may not
actually be a villain she knows what
she's supposed to do she knows what her
role
is and it almost seems like she's
conflicted between her loyalty to the
tva
and what her role describes and the hard
decisions she has to make and like
what's actually going on but it could
also be one of these things where she
knows that they're not
all created by the tva like she knows
that they're variants whatever they want
to call them but like they all had lives
before
and they were snatched up and brought in
there because she's the judge seemingly
she's the highest ranking person
outside of the the timekeepers
themselves she knows what's going on but
at the end of the day it's one of those
things where it's like but it's for the
greater good so like yeah it sucks that
i have to do it but i'll do it
nonetheless she doesn't strike me as a
villain
she strikes me as a prick but she
doesn't strike me as a villain
so in any event i think it's kind of a
it's a wild thing
right so let's talk about a few things
here right the time keepers
and let's talk about that post-credits
scene so here's the thing the
timekeepers
as soon as they walked into that room
and you saw the timekeeper sitting there
i was like oh my god man maybe it really
isn't miss minutes you know like maybe
it really is a time keepers are actually
alive like they they really are there
and they do exist and they're overseeing
all this stuff i had to turn on
on subtitles man i could understand a
damn thing those guys were saying man i
was like okay let's turn the subtitles
find out what's going on here like it
was
it was a cool little cool little little
tidbit there but like as soon as one of
them was decapitated and you found out
it was a robot i was like
miss minutes man miss minutes is the one
behind it all
that theory came right back i don't you
know honestly here's the thing about
theory crafting i don't care if i'm
right or wrong
i just like having fun with it that's
the that's the important thing guys just
have fun
don't focus on whether or not you're
right or wrong it doesn't really matter
if you are
it's just a tv show but it's it's a cool
thing right it's a it's a cool little
thing here so so this post credit scene
right this post credit scene is pretty
wild because this really
begs a lot of questions one it looks
like they've been capturing loki's for
quite some time those are the only three
that we saw right you saw a bose for
loki who
is most likely like red nor vel or a
loki from like earth 691
he's one of those versions of loki out
there probably the one just ended up
becoming worthy of lifting mjolnir and
that's basically it the hammer he has
looks like it was built so maybe it's
just like that ultimate universe version
of loki that basically uses like the
ultimate universe version of thor's
hammer they don't look exactly the same
and in fact that hammer looks
starkly different from the one from the
ultimate universe but at the end of the
day
that one looks like it was manufactured
and the one in the ultimate universe was
basically built in marvel comics but
regardless you've also got kid loki
kid loki's cool man all right so so at
the time that i'm recording this video
on comments explained i'm going to have
like a 20 minute long 20 to 25 minute
long explanation video
on kid loki but here's the quick little
dirty breakdown of his character right
so what you have was a story called
siege on asgard and the quick little
explanation here is that asgard was
basically rebuilt in brockton oklahoma
by thor after the events of ragnarok
when thor and all the asgardians and
asgard were destroyed when he basically
destroyed the world tree and so when
loki came back after taking over the
body of lady sif and becoming lady loki
he basically believed that like asgard
was too good for humanity
and it should exist in his own dimension
so he allied himself with norman osborn
who was the director of
shield who basically rebranded shield
into hammer and then
launched an attack on asgard in the
hopes that the asgardians would say okay
fine earth's two primitive whatever
we're not staying here we're gonna go
back home again the exact opposite
happened
instead crazy things popped off asgard
was totally destroyed and loki was
killed
loki actually made a deal with hella to
have his name removed from the books of
hell
basically meaning that when he died he
would just be resurrected and he came
back in the form of kid loki but with no
memory of his own past he had no idea
who he was didn't know that he was the
god of mischief or anything like that it
was a complete and total clean slate so
that's kind of the origin of kid loki
broken down in what maybe like
two minutes or something on those lines
and then you got classic loki right
who's played by richard e grant classic
loki looks awesome but what they
basically tell loki here is
if you stay here you're gonna die now
there's a few possibilities we can
extrapolate here
with what little we got
there's a few things we can extrapolate
here one they're in the city of new york
right so it's obviously an alternate
earth and you can pick up a few things
based on that one the giant skyline and
two the avengers tower in the background
which is like
leaning to one side so maybe that's an
alternate reality where the invasion of
new york went off without a hitch the
whole world was conquered and just laid
waste to maybe that's the world of like
future king loki right the one who
obliterated all life on earth in marvel
comics but regardless of the situation
they're basically in new york the next
thing
is i don't believe those are the only
three loki's who were there i think
there's more
i think there's more besides them but
like they're the ones who were just kind
of there when he arrived now did they
know he was coming
like we don't really know right we don't
really have that figured out i mean we
don't know how long he was there before
he woke up right like maybe it was just
one of those things
like oh my god a portal opened and loki
fell out all right come on y'all let's
let's go get him man like they sent him
more of him over here
let's go get him like they went to went
to go find him and he was just he was
just kind of laying there so there's a
few things that we don't really know
we don't have a time frame in terms of
how long he's been there the other thing
is why is it that if he stays there that
he's gonna die the place
looks like a post-apocalyptic landscape
it looks derelict right like
there's not a whole lot there i think
it'd be awesome if it was the man god
who was just like
hunting loki's across the world the man
gog is amazing those of you guys who
don't know what that is
man gog was the result of what happened
when odin wiped out a whole civilization
and the last remnants of that
civilization
channeled all their hatred and anger at
odin into a singular being and then it
became man god when
this guy shows up even odin his pants
it's a big deal right like odin is
terrified of the man god
you cannot kill the man god the best you
can do is just hold him off
or imprison him or something like that
but he's immortal and eternal he cannot
he cannot be killed it's kind of a crazy
thing right he's a he's a nuts character
but
i don't know what's leading to the
deaths of all these different uh these
different loki's right if he stays there
is he gonna die but that post-credit
scene looks awesome man because we see
these very
these different versions of loki there
and that begs the question why
are they there and my initial thought
was okay so maybe it's one of these
things where like miss minutes operating
behind the scenes timekeepers whoever's
in charge
they came to the realization somewhere
along the line that every version of
loki out there
will at some point in time develop the
ability to travel
beyond their existing universe and
create alternate realities
and so they just wait until that version
of loki achieves that ability then they
snatch them up and they throw them in
there which would kind of explain why it
is that they waited
until loki had the cosmic cube and then
broke the laws of his universe and then
went back there it could also be one of
these things where loki is genuinely
immortal now here's the thing about
immortality that we can kind of use for
mobile comics and apply to the mcu
although the marvel cinematic universe
might change it in marvel comics people
often times confuse
immortality with invulnerability
immortality in marvel comics basically
just means you'll never die of old age
and you'll never die of disease
and that's it right everything else is
just a compliment to immortality so you
could come across somebody who's
immortal
and you could chop their head off
assuming the weapon you had was of
sufficient strength so
long as their head stays separated from
their body they'll never be able to come
back but the important thing here is
that invulnerability is in and of itself
as you guys would expect
the inability or the exceedingly high
difficulty level that comes with
injuring someone so if you have an
insane level of durability
and you're immortal well then you're
basically a demigod like a really good
example of a person who
is immortal and then also has
exceedingly high levels of
invulnerability is a villain like
apocalypse right like he is inherently
immortal that's his that's his power
right he's a mutant who is legitimately
immortal that makes him something called
an
external a legitimately immortal mutant
that will never die of old age or
disease
but somebody of sufficient power could
kill apocalypse and the reason why is
because while he's not inherently
invulnerable
and didn't have high levels of
invulnerability in marvel comics he
eventually made a deal with the
celestials the beings that you're going
to see in the eternals film he made a
deal with them to borrow some of their
technology
which grants him high levels of
invulnerability that's why it's so hard
to kill him so i thought that
immortality thing kind of needed to be
fleshed out a little bit it could be
that in the marvel cinematic universe
that loki's just legitimately immortal
right every time he dies he comes back
as somebody else right
it always repeats itself he just always
comes back but the biggest issue that
you have
is why the tva is snatching up these
versions of loki why they're grabbing
so many of them and then seemingly
pruning them or dropping them off
right i mean maybe one of these things
that they brought them in and they they
tried to make them all tva agents and
they defected and then in turn they just
dropped them off there
i imagine they were all pruned for
different reasons i mean silvia was kind
of on the run and maybe that's maybe
that was the process right maybe that
was the idea that sylvie was an example
right an instance whereby loki's are not
supposed to exist
loki's are not supposed to be there but
if loki's are not supposed to exist
why wasn't loki snatched up earlier like
the instant he was born why was it why
was it that loki was not snatched up as
a little kid right in the same way that
sylvie was
and then taken to the tva so there's a
lot of possibilities here right like a
lot of things that could happen
that's one of the big struggles that you
have when you're talking about like a
30-second post-credit scene is
what do you do with it right like what
do you what do you do with this little
bit of information so anyway guys uh
thank you all for watching i hope you
guys enjoyed the episode as much as i
did
and i will catch you all later peace